Conspiracy theories have been around for a
long time.
However, a new set of political conspiracies is gaining
traction as a growing number of Americans
appear ready to embrace these fantastic and
sometimes dangerous ideas.
Not all Americans appear equally likely to believe in conspiracies.
They tend to be more common on the political right.
But one group appears particularly susceptible.
A new survey finds that white evangelical
Protestants are consistently more likely than
other Americans to embrace political conspiracies,
whether it is QAnon or the Deep State.
There are a few reasons for this: First, white evangelicals
are more socially segregated than other
Americans — they are more likely to be
surrounded by people who share their politics.
This means their views tend to be reinforced,
rather than challenged.
Second, they share a deep and abiding trust in
Donald Trump, who has well-documented history
of trafficking in these conspiracies
and engaging in falsehoods.
And finally, white evangelicals are uniquely distrustful
of the mainstream media, making them more
likely to seek out alternative sources of
information about news and politics.
Do you see the rise of political conspiracies in the US posing a unique threat to our society?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and SUBSCRIBE for more research and videos from AEI.